"The Batman" is back and better than ever.
At 2019's DC FanDome event, the first teaser
of "The Batman" was released to the world,
and it promised to be a spectacle from the
get-go. Now that some lucky audiences have
been able to check out the movie, it's confirmed
that this film is everything it was suspected
of being — a riveting dark thriller with
one of the best Batmans ever to don the cowl.
Even before fans were able to get themselves
in seats, critics and press members were able
to see Matt Reeves' take on the Dark Knight,
and they too — for the most part — were
beyond impressed. Some of the first reactions
to "The Batman" called it "sensational," "gripping,"
and "one helluva movie." When it comes to
our newest Caped Crusader, it was also said
that Robert Pattinson might just be your new
favorite Batman.
Of course, critics and audiences don't always
align — unless we're talking about Christopher
Nolan's "The Dark Knight" — so let's see
what the fans had to say on Twitter about
"The Batman" and if it lives up to all the
hype.
"What is the price for your blind eye?"
As to be expected, the biggest thing fans
are talking about on Twitter is Robert Pattinson's
portrayal of Batman and Bruce Wayne — which
are two very different things, by the way.
It's hard to find a criticism of Battinson
on the bird app, with many praising his performance
as the Dark Knight.
One User kept it simple, writing,
"I admit I'm in love with Robert Pattinson's
Batman"
Meanwhile, another excitedly exclaimed,
"Just saw #TheBatman and honestly Robert Pattinson
was born to play this role. DAMN!"
Moviegoers are ecstatic over Pattinson's ability
to capture the essence of the eponymous character
as well as his billionaire counterpart.
One fan made a definitive statement, tweeting,
"Yeah... Robert Pattinson is the best Bruce
Wayne/Batman combo"
The rest of the cast is being said to have
delivered incredible performances as well.
One fan could barely keep their excitement
contained, writing,
"Pattinson f—ing killed it. Paul Dano as
Riddler was straight out of a horror movie.
Colin [Farrell], John Turturro, Zoe Kravitz,
and Jeffrey Wright were all phenomenal. Matt
Reeves made a f—ing masterpiece of a movie.
Holy s—."
"Whoa! Take it easy, sweetheart."
While "The Batman" may be a standalone movie,
there was no way this new adventure wasn't
going to be compared to "The Dark Knight,"
which many long hailed as the best superhero
movie of all time.
Fans who were able to catch the new film early
started comparing it to the Christopher Nolan
film right away.
One fan commented,
"#TheBatman is the second best superhero movie
of all time, just behind The Dark Knight"
Another fan lapped on more praise, saying
"@mattreevesLA gave me #TheBatman film of
my dreams. Something I've been waiting for
since Batman: The Animated Series. I've never
seen something & have been absolutely sure
if something but I'm 100% sure this is the
best Batman film we've ever gotten. & my absolute
favorite ever."
Overall, it seems like "The Batman" has cemented
itself as one of the greatest comic book movies
of all time. While it technically is a superhero
movie, it doesn't necessarily feel like one.
"The Batman" is an action-thriller to its
core, and fans couldn't be happier with it.
Some of the comments included -
"10/10 This is the live-action Batman film
I've always wanted."
"#TheBatman WAS SO AMAZING IM SHAKING."
"Just walked out of #TheBatman and I have
no words"
"They nailed #TheBatman from start to finish."
"#TheBatman is a masterpiece. One of the best
superhero movies ever."
All in all, fans of the Dark Knight are not
going to be disappointed with "The Batman,"
which sounds from all reactions like it's
been worth the years of hype.
"When that light hits the sky, it's not just
a call – it's a warning."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one.